jeopardy champion with the show's
longest ever winning streak
is returning as its first interim host
the news comes just two weeks after the
death of longtime host alex trebek
here's a look at how ken jennings and
his history with the show
ken what is the waltons that's right uh
let's take the name game for 200.
it's been 16 years since ken jennings
first took jeopardy by storm
who is the skipper yes he went on a
historic and record-breaking run that
year
ultimately winning 74 games and more
than 2 million dollars
you were an excellent player you caught
some good breaks and because of that
combination i'm going to say
that your record i don't think it'll
ever be broken jennings streak is still
unrivaled and now he's set to take on a
new jeopardy challenge
hosting the game show announced monday
that it would resume production next
week
with jennings as the first in a series
of interim guest
hosts there will only ever be one alex
trebek jennings tweeted but i'm honored
people love him he's a fan favorite
and for many fans it would probably be a
comfort to see
jennings on the screen elaine lowe is a
senior reporter with variety
she said it may be hard for viewers to
transition away from
alex trebek who hosted the show for 36
years
before losing a battle to pancreatic
cancer earlier this month
i think the best hope for anyone who is
stepping
behind that podium is really to
create their own new relationship with
these viewers and these fans at home
it's a relationship jennings has already
spent decades building
and he's openly credited the show with
changing his life
i remember running home from school
every day to watch the show
it was my favorite was my favorite show
even before it paid for my house here we
go in recent years jennings has stayed
involved with the game show
losing to ibm's watson artificial
intelligence technology in 2011
watson what is executor right and coming
back to win
jeopardy's greatest of all time
tournament this past january
but for me the greatest of all time
and now jeopardy's greatest ever
contestant becomes the first to fill the
shoes of its
legendary host now jeopardy hasn't
announced a permanent replacement for
trebek and will
unveil additional interim hosts in the
coming weeks denise
still ahead on